at 23 years old quojo tuanaboa has
already become something of a hero for
renters in the uk his social media
campaign forced one of europe's largest
house associations to take direct action
and fix the conditions people were
living in his campaigning followed by
nearly 50 000 people on twitter has
since been recognized by the government
who has vowed to name and shame
landlords who breach standards he told
me of his personal story with social
housing
quajo thanks so much for coming on the
show it's so nice um to see you thank
you uh and you're here
uh because you've become a very very
well-known figure for your campaigning
work around housing and the fight for
better housing for your own family and
also countless other people
and i'm going to bring some videos in a
bit about some of your campaigning
material but i wanted to start with you
and your story yeah so can you talk me
through
your own story your own experience and
tell me a bit about what happened to
your family
yeah so i've lived in um social housing
for the majority of of my life and um
disrepair has been a huge part of that
um i lived in temporary accommodation
many times and
one of which was a converted car garage
which was falling apart there was damp
there was mold um
just no somewhere where no one should be
living i then um with my my dad and my
two sisters moved to my current home now
which
again was completely falling apart but
we just took it in the end because it
was permanent social housing so my dad
didn't really have an option because he
had been waiting for years and years for
that
um and that was completely falling apart
again damp mold cockroaches no kitchen
no bathroom um mice
yeah so you so you so when you were a
little boy your dad was waiting to get a
permanent home for you on on what a
council waiting list yeah and you just
kept being moved around exactly yeah um
and
that there was a feeling especially for
him that he didn't want to complain so
although the place was falling apart um
in the temporary accommodation
especially because it was temporary
accommodation there's this huge fear and
not just with him but other tenants that
i've spoken to that if they do complain
they're at risk and your dad was a care
worker wasn't he was yes he looked after
the elderly yeah so your dad had
a very valuable job to his community
yeah but he couldn't get social housing
for him and his family no and he had
done that for for many years decades um
looking after the elderly so he was
essentially a key worker although it
wasn't referred to that back then he was
um and it was a struggle i mean we saw
it as children at the time how hard it
was for him and tell me about your dad
oh yeah well um
he's
he's no longer he felt he fell ill while
we were living in um my current property
now while it was falling apart so like i
described damp mold cockroaches and he
was diagnosed with esophageal cancer
stage one that rapidly progressed to
stage four but meanwhile he was being um
he was receiving medical treatment so he
was being fed for his stomach during
that time and he was bed-bound he
couldn't move um whilst there was
cockroaches and mice in the property
just somewhere where no one should have
been living never mind someone receiving
medical treatment
um for such a serious illness so he he
then passed away in january 2020 and the
fight continued in regards to
the poor housing that we was living in
i'm sorry i'm sorry you lost your dad
thank you um
yeah that's that's rough um
but your dad being ill
in the house in this these housing
conditions yeah is that was that the
trigger for you
is that when you started the campaign or
had you started that before i think so
whilst my dad was ill that was the sort
of main concern i mean housing was
parked to the side because it was just
about trying to get him better and we
thought he would
but then when he passed away and we
looked back in or i looked back in
hindsight i realized this was just
completely unacceptable how is it not
illegal
and he
was the sort of fire that i needed and
it's carried me up until today because
i'm very very determined that
and that no one should be living in
these conditions never mind people
receiving medical treatment but it's
happened time and time again and i've
seen it so he's very much the driving
force behind your dad's fire yeah that
drives you on and
i imagine he'd be incredibly proud of
you
you fought for your own family and got
much better conditions for your own for
your sisters right so you you did that
for your own family but you also
campaigned for other people and i think
we have some footage which uh i was
watching actually last night um it's on
you're all on your twitter feed let's
have a look at this is someone else's
house
here you can see um a cockroach alive
in the water still or it's just yeah
still alive now
and i wasn't recording but remind me so
you've got three kids yeah and what's
the youngest how old's the youngest
four and then it's a 12 year old
and 10 and a 10 year old and you said
you're younger so it's even fallen in
the house because the yeah because of
the leak and that's your landline cable
there yeah and that they've come to make
safe and where your washing machine's
supposed to be and plugged in it's not
working at all
so there you've got you've got black
rock you've got cockroaches you told me
that that mum
found a cockroach in her ear yeah a few
days before i went there um when i did
go there she she mentioned after i had
pulled back the child's mattress and
hundreds of cockroaches i came calling
out she said she often finds them
borrowed in their ears in the morning
and had to have a few um removed i mean
it's absolutely slum conditions that no
one should be allowed to live in
but they are unfortunately what happened
to that family if you so to get yes so i
highlighted the case on social media and
they were moved out within 24 hours they
were put into a hotel but i found out um
about two days ago that they will be
moved into permanent um
accommodation in the next two weeks and
it would be completely disrepair free
correct um so i'm glad that that feels
good yeah yeah that's why i do it that's
why i let's go on to
your politics or your political
influence yeah because
you how old 23 years old
were name-checked by no other than the
secretary of state for levelling up and
housing michael gove this week
how do you view that acclaim from
politicians for for what you
do
um
well
all i feel um is that it's about time so
when i'm meeting people like michael
gove and other politicians it's not a
sense it's nice to meet them i mean
having grown up in my background and
seeing them on tv it's nice to meet them
but i mean the context that i'm meeting
them in isn't great the reason i'm
meeting them is to highlight a national
crisis i think that's happening
um and i've managed to build a platform
where i can now hold not just housing
associations and social housing
providers accountable but also
politicians that um
don't unfortunately do as much as they
need to be doing to help um people do
you feel cross with him when you see him
given that it's the conservative party
that have been in power for 12 years i
mean
do you blame him um
yes i'd say i blame i blame the
government that's been in power for the
last decade because this is something
that has been complained about time and
time again but it's never unfortunately
been seen as priority this isn't
something that's been happening for a
year this has been going on for absolute
decades and unfortunately for the last
10 years or 12 years it's got
progressively worse and after grenfell
you would expect and you would have
expected for this to be top priority in
regards to regulation and social housing
providers and landlords being held
accountable but unfortunately
what five years on um
they they haven't been and i think it is
a national disgrace but i'm glad that
he's
acknowledged that and it is
acknowledging it and making the steps
and i think every single politician in
um
westminster should be screaming and
shouting from the rooftops about this
because i have no doubt in every single
constituency is a resident living in
poor social or housing not even just
social housing conditions in housing in
general and it shouldn't be happening
especially after grenfell the uk is the
fifth richest economy in the world
yet you've shown these conditions we are
a wealthy nation a very wealthy nation
you've shown these conditions are
commonplace 1.6 million homes in social
housing or private rented sector failed
to meet the government's good home
sanders why have people been forgotten
in this way is it cultural is it
political what what do you what do you
think it's a mixture i think between
both and the the fundamental thing is um
the lack of care like i mentioned before
it's not being seen as a priority is
that because people in government don't
experience it
almost definitely and it's i mean
having to deal with housing is a big
issue and i mean it's not going to be
bringing in money really for them so i
understand why they don't see it as a
priority but it should because it
affects millions of people's lives and
not just that i think it's also when we
look at westminster and diversity it's
very easy to tick a box when it comes to
race and also gender but what's not
looked at is class and the fact that
there's not class diversity in
westminster so how can they truly be
representative of the people people like
me people sat in their homes suffering
in social housing and truly say that
they are diverse and representative of
them because i can tell them frank
frankly they're they're not i was going
to ask you this i'll bring it up now
you've brought it up because you're a
serious campaigner you have a national
profile you're commanding the attention
of cabinets you're 23 years old i mean i
can't get over that how young and
influential you've become but you're a
young black man you're a young working
class black man
i was going to ask you what what's the
biggest barrier is it being black or is
it being working class was it both
i mean the mixture of the two just sets
you on a back foot completely i mean
there's a stigma that comes up around
with being a black male off of an estate
it's never a good one you're almost
looked down upon so for me to be able to
do this i wanted to be able to show
other people like me other black boys
off of an estate that it is possible um
to make change and that your voice does
matter because it does and collectively
it change can be brought about i mean in
the last year this has happened and
they've been supporting i have to give
massive thanks to the black community
especially um on my estate and on social
media that have constantly shared this
and been able to to to relate to the
situations that i've been highlighting
because for so long they've suffered
their parents have suffered
and they've just been ignored so if i
can help inspire them then that's what i
want to do with the work that i am doing
as well as creating change in in
government
and you do inspire people but you have
created change in government um the
queen's speech this week that's the
government's legislative program for the
next year contained measures to clamp
down on rogue landlords which is
directly attributable to you is that
enough do that does that go far enough
for you is that just the beginning of
this campaign for you i mean it was nice
hearing that in the queen queen speech i
have to say um but i want to know um
what
exactly that entails what changes are
being brought about i think there needs
to be a crackdown on landlords both
privately and social landlords they need
to be held accountable with the work
that i've been doing over the last year
highlighting not one um ceo or senior
manager for one of these social housing
providers have has lost their jobs but
had it been a situation where this was
in the nhs or any other public sector
people would have lost their jobs as a
result that's not enough accountability
there's not enough accountability and i
still don't believe there's enough care
there too and like i mentioned earlier
after grenfell there should be people
should be held accountable um within
housing and meeting or not meeting
regulation i've got a few more questions
out of time so quickly um
you have made incredible impact do you
ever see yourself being a politician i
think you did once tweet that you might
be trying to be the mayor of london so
you can't say that this comes from
nowhere this question yes um
well i thought about it and i mean for
change to happen yes i know i'm
screaming and shouting from outside but
i do believe it comes from
within two so um who knows i know so
maybe he's in two years i have to wait
and see did you join a political part if
you joined a political party i have to
say i'm very disappointed in um both of
them at the moment equally um so i
haven't uh yet
um whether i will i have to wait and see
but if i do i think do anything
politically it'll probably have to be
independent uh the way the current
political sphere looks okay okay so you
might go into politics so you might have
a look at running for london mayor watch
this space
right okay you also people might not
realize this you're also actually a
full-time student i don't know yeah i
mean you're very productive you're
clearly not down the bar like i was
you're very productive um you've just
finished your exams i have yesterday
three hour exam in the morning um
so that's my degree
over and i mean that for me was the
hardest hardest thing i think i've done
because on four occasions with my dad
passing away and becoming ill yeah i did
plan on dropping out so to be able to go
and care for your sisters yeah sort
everything out exactly and it must be
really hard yeah so to be able to do it
that's a huge accomplishment and i know
that's one of the last things he
remembered was the fact that i'm in uni
and i'm going to finish my degree so
were you the first person for your
family to go to university i was but me
and my sister are both graduating this
year wow he must have been so proud of
you all yeah so you you you're going to
get a business studies degree
you said that you're hoping to get a 2-1
i think you might get first i think
there might be some false modesty there
or not well not just genuine actually
and you but you've got an ambition to be
an artist yes that's always been um my
my main goal i mean from the age of 14 i
taught myself how to paint portraits so
i've been doing that on the side while
studying my degree and everything else
and that's what i hope to go back into i
mean long term that is what i want to
want to do when it comes to your
campaign on housing how do you define
success what would it be for you you
think i've done it success for me would
be when my phone stops going off and
from tenants complaining that they're
complaining that they've been ignored
constantly and asking for my help as a
result
okay kojo thanks so much for coming and
joining us thank you so much it's great
talking so i enjoyed it thank you